cours de sciences sociales aujourd'hui
l'exclusion sociale la source utilisée
pour cet exposé le dictionnaire
d'économie et de sciences sociales des
éditions hatier l'exclusion sociale peut
se définir comme une rupture du lien
social
les exclus sont des individus atomisés
isolé qui n'appartiennent plus à un
groupe de base de la société comme la
famille ou le groupe de voisinage mise à
l'écart n'est en plus de soutien
d'aucune sorte il perd peu à peu les
repères sociaux qui les maintenaient
encore insérés dans le tissu social ils
en arrivent même à ne plus fréquenter
les institutions caritatives qui
pourraient les aider à conserver un pied
dans la société
la perte du lien social s'accompagne
évidemment aussi d'une image de soi
dévaloriser l'exclusion sociale résulte
d'un processus de cumul des précarités
des handicaps sociaux
c'est un processus infernal aux
multiples facettes dont la plus courante
conduit du chômage durable à la
destruction du tissu familial et à la
perte de logement le chômage la pauvreté
l'âge l'absence de diplôme
les problèmes de santé et la faible
insertion dans les réseaux familiaux ou
sociaux constituent des facteurs de
précarité qui peuvent conduire à
l'exclusion sociale processus de
fragilisation du lien social de
désaffiliation au cours duquel
l'individu perd un peu à peu les liens
installé avec d'autres individus ou des
groupes d'individus et pouvant aboutir à
la mise à l'écart de la société d'un
avis d un individu ou d'un groupe
d'individus l'exclusion se construit pas
ruptures successives elle est rarement
total ainsi tout d'abord il arrive qu'un
individu perde son emploi par la suite
face aux difficultés financières
il perd également son logement s'en suit
cette spirale infernale qu'il conduit
vraiment à l'exclusion sociale
ils portent des habits et le lien qui
est généralement le dernier aaron là les
liens familiaux
le tout est maintenant de savoir comment
mesurer et observer ce phénomène
d'exclusion sociale on peut se baser sur
certains indicateurs
tout d'abord le nombre des sdf
évidemment est un bon indicateur de
l'exclusion sociale puisque ceux ci sont
vraiment le l'archétype de l'exclusion
sociale de la vie du de l'individu exclu
mais il est très difficile de mesurer le
nombre de sdf d'une société étant donnée
la mobilité et bien sûr le mans que de
données statistiques qu'on peut avoir
étant donné qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
facilement identifiables il ya aussi
l'illettrisme le fait de ne pas savoir
lire et écrire compter et calculé fait
qu' on est exclue socialement que faire
quand on ne sait pas remplir un simple
formulaire évidemment l'illettrisme peut
varier en fonction des méthodes
utilisées enfin le chômage de longue
durée montre aussi une forme de
l'exclusion
parce que le chômage d'exclusion
rassemble tous ceux qui se sont
progressivement enfermée dans un chômage
de longue durée et qui après une
première période de chômage sont
considérés comme ayant des difficultés
de réinsertion en raison de leur âge par
exemple de leur niveau de qualification
relativement faible et en définitive il
n'arrive pas à se remettre sur le marché
du travail et donc de ce fait sont
exclues socialement
quels sont les facteurs d'exclusion
sociale
tout d'abord le chômage de longue durée
on l'a dit conduit à une exclusion du
marché du travail qui un prix 20
individus de certains revenus mais de
deux rivaux si l'individu de certains
liens sociaux certains individus sont
sans avoir accès à un emploi
elles ne vont plus rencontré personne
étant isolée au niveau familial où est
entré peu d'amis la société de
consommation et certains comportements
qui sont liées vont conduire aussi plus
facilement certains individus vers
l'exclusion pense notamment au
surendettement
les crédits faciles et les tentations
qui sont vraiment pléthorique à nos
sociétés vont conduire certains à lundi
le plus fragilisé vers un processus une
spirale qui va les amener finalement à
l'exclusion l'évolution de l'institution
familiale évidemment le fait que le lien
familial est de moins en moins fort dans
nos sociétés on divorce plus facilement
qu'avant et les familles monoparentales
sont plus présentes dans la société et
donc on n'a plus ce filet de sécurité
qui était la famille comme par le passé
enfin il doit être dit que ces
différents éléments peuvent se cumuler
et certains individus vraiment de fait
de leur appartenance à des certaines
catégories socio professionnelles ou
socio culturels vont un certain moment à
agréger ou additionner ses différentes
faces et les fragilités qui vont les
conduire clairement dans un processus
d'exclusion
je vous remercie pour votre attention
n'oubliez pas le petit questionnaire sur
ce coup le dit et nous nous retrouvons
en classe pour vos éventuelles questions